dancing can be found all over the animal
world displays of Grace and strength are
often used to attract mates or
intimidate competitors
but in honeybees the waggle dance is so
much more than self-promotion imagine
that you're a bee flying out to find a
food source and you keep going there and
coming back if you were to draw a little
map of that you would see this portion
which is mostly straight going out to
the food source and then curving to come
back going out to this food source
curving come back essentially that's
what the waggle dance is it's a
miniature map of where the bee goes the
waggle dance contains three critical
pieces of information
the direction of the waggle gives the
direction of the food source the
duration of the waggle indicates how far
away the food is and the repetition of
the whole dance indicates how good the
food source is
the more exciting the food source the
more rapidly the bee will repeat its
dance
researchers recently designed an
experiment aimed at understanding the
role of social learning in this complex
Behavior so we were trying to learn
about the importance of social
information for bees honeybees are
famous for being incredibly social so
when they're born they start off as
nurses working inside the nest and as
they get older they start to work
outside the nest as trash bees guard
bees and finally as foragers so what
happens as a Bee gets older at a certain
age she starts to become very interested
in other foragers and in particular it
seems that almost all of them are
following waggle dances of older more
experienced bees before they themselves
try to waggle dance in order to study
the role of social learning from more
experienced dancers the researchers set
up experimental colonies where bees were
all the same age and compared them to
control colonies with bees of all ages
where the young could learn from the old
we caught them on their first venture
out the first time they were out in the
world trying to find flowers we needed
to make sure that we observe their first
waggle dances
we gave them an incredible food source
this Rich sugar feeder and they came
back and they started to dance
so what we found is that when bees do
their first dances in the experimental
colonies they were pointing in different
directions on average more than the
first dances of control bees that had
teachers the experimental bees started
off making more errors than the control
B's but they were able to correct this
over time as they matured meanwhile the
control bees had a low level of error
from the start but held throughout their
lives the experimental bees also made
errors in how they communicated distance
the distance to feeders was always the
same for all of the bees but the
experimental bees always danced longer
than the control bees
now when we looked at them later in life
we would think maybe they could have
corrected themselves after all they were
watching the dances of other bees and
they were practicing they never did they
always overshot so it looked like that
was acquired and sort of fixed for the
lifetime of the bee this led the
researchers to consider whether there
was a critical learning period for
certain tasks in a complex Behavior like
a waggle dance
in many languages we see a kind of
sensitive phase classically this has
been called imprinting it's almost as if
there's a space inside the brain that is
open for a limited period of time to
that kind of learning
we know the same thing in many types of
songbirds we even know about this in
naked mole rats so
is there something that once it's set
inside the B brain that the beat can't
really change that and it looks like the
distance in coding is that thing
the improvements that the experimental
bees made in their waggle angle showed
that learning some things without
teachers is possible
but the persistent errors in their
distance encoding suggests that learning
this particular skill from experienced
dancers is critical
researchers are now interested in
whether errors made in one generation
might be passed down to the next
in many ways our understanding of animal
culture is based upon the teaching and
the transmission of this kind of
information so what I would like to know
is where learning is involved what is
the actual reason for that well this
cultural transmission may just make
difficult tasks easier to learn
scientists suspect that it could play a
larger role helping species or even
individual colonies adapt to various and
changing environments